[Musique]
le club k Energie c'est un recroupement
de compétences d'experts de différentes
sociétés qui ont envie d' vrer sur le
territoire pour faciliter la transition
énergétique et surtout inventer et
mettre en place des des bacs à sables
des expérimentations autour de
[Musique]
l'énergie au départ on a créé le club il
y a 10 ans effectivement pour travailler
sur la mutualisation des réflexions de
différentes entreprises par rapport aux
problématiques de la réduction des gaz à
effet de serre on a mener différentes
actions d'expérimentation et aussi de
mise en place on a parlé de skich cher
qui est le covoiturage d'une voiture une
idée de deux trois entreprises qui sont
mises ensemble pour pouvoir
effectivement effectuer des des trajets
de court ou moyenne distance avec le
covoiturage des solutions économiques
intéressantes et qui préservve la
planète
[Musique]
nous n'imaginions pas lorsque nous avons
créé le club clima énergie donc en 2013
que nous aurions à vivre une crise
énergétique comme celle que nous avons
connu en 2022 2023 celle-ci a montré
encore plus d'actualité par rapport à
nos réflexions nos acteurs nos partenair
nous on dit mais comment on fait
l'évolution a été de travailler sur les
sujets de l'énergie puisque très
rapidement s'est posé la question par
rapport à nos partenaires de comment
réduire le coût de l'énergie et comment
réduire être plus efficient dans la
manière de consommer son énergie
c'est-à-dire de mettre en place des
procédures des processus qui permettra
de consommer moins les prochains défis
du club clima energy c'est d'essayer de
d'expérimenter des nouvels formats de je
dirais d'énergie donc on passe notamment
à l'autoconsommation c'est quelque chose
qu'on essaie de mettre en place dans les
différentes communes en liant toujours
l'aspect privé puisque en terme de je
dirais établissement public on est assez
armé pour mettre en place des
expérimentations pour répondre à leur
demande